[Música]
ah
muy buenas noches estamos con las
energías bien puestas y les voy a hacer
una pregunta que no es retórica que será
lo que estoy levantando en mi mano si
alguno recuerda lo que yo tengo aquí en
mi mano quien cuando ha sido la última
vez que ustedes han comprado un libro
físico si está
es la pregunta que yo me he hecho porque
me dado cuenta de que estamos viviendo
realmente tiempos extraordinarios nunca
en la historia de la humanidad habíamos
tenido tanta información al alcance de
nuestras manos en cualquier momento y en
cualquier lugar por eso considero que
somos personas realmente privilegiadas
porque gracias a los nuevos dispositivos
podemos estar incluso hiper conectados
al internet y esto puede significar algo
bueno pero también puede significar
algunos retos para nuestra educación y
para nuestra formación no sé si ustedes
recuerdan un experimento que se hizo
hace muchos años a través de los años 60
con un tocayo mío que se llama iván pub
los que nos hablaban de los perros de
pavlov si este concepto básicamente él
es el padre del condicionamiento de la
teoría conductista entonces recordamos
básicamente ese experimento se trataba
de que había un estímulo que en este
caso era la comida había un disparador
que era la campanilla que sonaba y los
perros que estaban encerrados ni bien
escuchaban la campanita se abría la
puerta iban y se alimentaban
directamente de sus alimentos entonces
así fue acondicionando los perros
durante una y otra vez y lo más
interesante que él descubrió fue que en
algún momento directamente sonaba la
campanita y los perritos y empezaban a
aliviar sin que no haya ningún tipo de
alimento ahí de por medio yo considero
que hoy en día muchos de nosotros somos
los nuevos perros de pavlov sí porque
porque si nos damos cuenta que estamos
tranquilos tal vez estudiando en nuestra
casa estamos trabajando y de repente
suena este aparatito y suena de repente
e inmediatamente nosotros empezamos a
salivar si inconscientemente y sacamos
el dispositivo y vemos alguien está
escribiendo alguien está llamando debe
ser algo sumamente importante debido a
muerte si inmediatamente dejamos de
hacer todo lo que estamos haciendo y nos
ponemos a contestar corrector entonces
eso puede significar también un doble
peligro por eso
pregunto a ustedes cuando ha sido la
última vez que ustedes han puesto su
aparatito
en off sobre todo en el tema de
notificaciones ya no reciben
notificaciones y cuando cuando podrían
tener acceso a wifi o a sus datos
móviles no tienen apagado cuántas veces
lo pagan su celular al día
y nos recordemos esta imagen muy
simpática muchos empezamos a salivar y
es que este libro físico que tengo mi
mano ha sido digitalizado gracias a los
nuevos programas que existen hoy día yo
puedo leer todo el contenido de este
libro en la comodidad de mi mano y no
solamente un libro sino puedo tener un
montón de libros sí porque estamos
viviendo los tiempos donde podemos
diferenciar lo que son las diez
tradicionales de las nuevas tecnologías
de la información y comunicación dentro
de las tic's tradicionales
podemos hablar por ejemplo de la voz
humana ustedes saben que la voz humana
es la tics tradicional por experiencia y
ha sido la cual nosotros hemos podido
transmitir información desde nuestros
ancestros en la época de las cavernas
con esa comunicación oral e intangible
afortunadamente más adelante se ha
podido hacer
otro tipo de transmisión que ya no ha
sido tan intangibles y no se ha podido
escribir ahí viene el tema de los
papiros viene el tema de la tinta más
adelante hablamos de la revolución de
1492 que fue la imprenta de gutenberg y
más adelante hablamos del telégrafo del
teléfono de la radio de la televisión e
incluso del vídeo hasta ahí son las tics
tradicionales pero cuando hablamos de
las nuevas tecnologías de la información
y comunicación estamos hablando del auge
de lo que ha sido la conjunción del
software y del hardware que se han unido
por medio del internet y mediante por
ejemplo estos aparatitos estos gadgets
que se llaman smartphones yo puedo estar
conectado al internet en cualquier
momento y en cualquier lugar ese
concepto se llama ubicuidad entonces es
como si dijéramos que él
werner salió a la calle entonces yo
puede estar conectado e hiper conectados
al internet entonces muchos con eso
porque a veces podemos también llegar a
saturar nos y eso podría llegar a ser un
problema entonces cómo ven las tics
tradicionales y las tiene tics son dos
aguas totalmente diferentes
y aquí viene un concepto muy simpático
que se llaman los info productos que es
único producto podemos decir que un
informe producto está queda saber humano
que ha sido empaquetado sistemáticamente
para resolver una determinada
problemática de tal forma que le ofrezca
al que lo consume el punto de vista de
uno o de varios expertos en la materia
en base a sus investigaciones
experiencia y conocimiento destilado
entonces los info productos como sea
este libro me resuelve una determinada
problemática si obviamente no estoy
hablando de ciencia ficción o novelas
románticas los otros géneros estamos
hablando de que me ayudan a resolver
cierto tipo de problemas ahora lo
interesante es cuando yo puedo pasar de
este libro físico a un libro digital
conocido como un ebook en formato pdf
move y el que yo quiera pasamos de la
industria de la música de los famosos
discos de vinilo a los cines y más
adelante a formatos más interesantes
como el mp3
pasamos del vídeo al mp4 pasamos de
estas conferencias en vivo y en directo
a seminarios web lo que se llaman los
webinarios si entonces estos info
productos nos han estado rodeando a lo
largo de toda nuestra vida aunque no nos
hayamos dado cuenta y los formatos ahora
del osinfor productos digitales tienen
una característica muy simpática que es
que el costo marginal es igual a cero
que será eso del costo marginal se los
dejo para que abrí un poquito más
adelante pero lo que sí quiero decirles
es que cuando nosotros pensamos en
estudiar muchos sobre todo los de mi
generación que somos la generación x que
estamos pintando algunas caritas
decidimos estudiar y no tengo que ir a
la universidad a la biblioteca
y tanger arme un montón de libros si eso
era el estudio para la gente de mi
generación pero afortunadamente para la
generación milenia la generación y la
generación z el estudio ya no es esto si
cuando habrá sido la última vez que
ustedes han visitado una hemeroteca o
una biblioteca
hoy en día podemos ver que la educación
a distancia el famoso learning o el
mobile learning está rompiendo barreras
que antiguamente eran un arrancas tanto
en términos económicos de costo y de
distancia fíjense esta foto que mónica
qué bonita esa foto
cuando quiero que recuerden cuando ha
sido la primera vez es que ustedes
fueron acompañados por sus padres
seguramente cuando estaban en kínder o
pre kinder y fueron al colegio
y dos del amado a propósito gracias
mamita marta por todas las enseñanzas
que me has dado y que más inculcado en
mi vida recuerda en este momento cuando
vamos de la mano de nuestros padres a
educarnos y ellos serán los responsables
que nosotros tengamos una educación de
calidad y de calidez si ese modelo bajo
cual casi todos nosotros hemos aprendido
algo se llama el modelo pedagógico
pedagógico porque esa enseñanza para
niños sí pero nosotros ya estamos un
poquito más grandecitos necesitamos un
modelo mucho más ágil que se llama el
modelo andragogía y este modelo
andragogía tiene un resultado muy
interesante en un modo de aprender y de
estudiar que se llaman las famosas box
estos cursos online masivos y abiertos
qué significa eso que yo para aprender
algo lo único que necesito es tener una
conexión a internet mediante algún tipo
de dispositivo
puede ser un dispositivo móvil una
tableta un smartphone o también puede
ser simplemente una computadora si
veintisiete tenga un dispositivo
conectado en internet pueda aprender lo
que yo quiera abierto porque éstas no
tienen ningún tipo de restricción para
lo que yo quiero llegar a aprender a
diferencia de los colegios universidades
o institutos donde me exigen que yo
tengo un grado mínimo académico en el
caso de las motos no existe ningún tipo
de restricción para que ustedes aprendan
lo que quieran aprender masivos porque
pueden entrar como un estado hablar cien
personas mil personas en el año 2012
existe fija bien el gráfico es la punta
de la evolución de lo que vendrían a ser
las motos el año 2012
yo fui fue precisamente ese año donde
hice mi primer móvil y éramos
aproximadamente 50.000 estudiantes
entonces si un colega docente le dio
imagínate
gestionar un curso de 50 mil estudiantes
mundial estás loco que están pasando así
pero lo interesante del modelo de las
box es que te permite llegar y hacer
cursos para cientos de miles de personas
dispersadas por todo el mundo
masivos abiertos significa también de
estos muchos de estos cursos tienen un
costo una valoración mínima más que nada
es un costo simbólico si a diferencia de
una licenciatura o de un posgrado que te
puede costar varios miles de dólares si
lo interesante de estos de estos cursos
online masivos y abiertos es que como
ven en la gráfica a partir del año 2015
las motos se convierten en un
catalizador de la educación formal por
lo tanto este modelo andrológico que
puede estar basado en modos requiere de
algunos principios fundamentales en
primer instancia que ustedes sean
capaces de auto gestionar su aprendizaje
es decir que ustedes puedan desarrollar
su propia ruta formativa yo quiero
aprender esto a diferencia de la
educación tradicional donde te imponen
una currícula que dice tú si quieres ser
licenciado en tal cosa tienes que
aprender esto lo otro etcétera ya te lo
dan todo me si en este modelo estamos
diciendo que tú diseñas qué cositas
quieres aprender en base a que a
experiencias previas es decir tú ya
tienes que tener cierto conocimiento
para saber qué es lo que necesitas pero
aquí lo interesante de esto es que
tienes que avanzar rápido tienes que
avanzar rápido porque tú quieres
aprender destrezas y habilidades no
puedes estar esperando cinco años ocho
años o diez años para graduar si hay
cursos muy gustosos derivaciones que
duran a veces unos cuantos meses pero
con esos pocos meses puedes encontrar
tal vez el trabajo soñado que siempre
estaba buscando y aquí también entre un
principio de horizontalidad
a diferencia de la educación tradicional
que es vertical donde está un profesor y
el profesor transmite información y
ustedes son simplemente receptores
sujetos pasivos desinformación cuando
estamos hablando de principios de orisol
mentalidad que estamos diciendo que el
profesor se convierte más bien en un
facilitador en un orientador en una
persona que les va a dar simplemente las
pautas de lo que ustedes quieren hacer
pero que ustedes mismos pueden generar
comunidad aprender y enseñar entre
ustedes mismos sí y eso es lo bonito
también de este sistema móvil que no
solamente está hecho para profesores que
van a dar clases no sino que es abierto
también para que ustedes mismos puedan
ayudar a otras personas y que ustedes
mismos puedan destilar su información
para hacer un acto humanitario de
enseñar a otras personas a lograr sus
metas y lograr sus objetivos
evidentemente necesitan ser también
críticos con lo que van a hacer y tienen
que tomar acción eso es muy importante
por lo tanto algunos principios bajo los
cuales se sustenta este modelo
andragogía vendría a ser tiene que
convertirse en autoridad es decir que
ustedes aprendan sus propios métodos y
modos de enseñanza que sean auto
motivadores auto motivadores qué difícil
es levantarse todas las mañanas y
motivarse a sí mismo y no que sea la
mamá o el papá o no a alguien que nos
esté sacando de nuestra zona de confort
y vaya a estudiar no el profesor que
está plaza
no en este caso estamos hablando de que
tiene que haber por eso un fervor de lo
que tú estás queriendo aprender que te
motive todos los días que te evalúen a
ti mismo imagínate que nunca más tenga
que dar exámenes ante un profesor porque
el único evaluador que vas a tener eres
tú mismo y tú mismo mi amigo no te
puedes engañar tú tienes que aprender
a conocerte a ti mismo y qué difícil es
eso de conocernos a nosotros mismos
quiénes somos qué queremos realmente y
dónde nos proyectamos en los próximos
años y eso es muy importante
auto conocemos y una vez que nosotros
tenemos todos estos autos que estamos
hablando acá podemos ser como nuestro
amigo michael sheiman tal vez es un
nombre medio raro que les suene pero les
comento que es un hijo de padres
bolivianos es el primer boliviano por
así decirlo que ha tenido el privilegio
de trabajar en dos de las empresas más
grandes del mundo en materia de
tecnológica
estamos hablando de microsoft y estamos
hablando de web en facebook y a la edad
de menos de 20 años una persona muy
joven entonces alguien se puede
preguntar tal vez le despertó al foro
había dicho oiga seguramente esta
persona ha debido estudiar en las
mejores universidades
del mundo tal vez de estados unidos o de
europa y habrá gastado tal vez cientos
de miles de dólares haber endeudado tal
vez para aprender lo que sabe y estar
donde está
sí pero les voy a resumir el concepto
que les he dicho en las propias palabras
de macros sheiman quien dijo un día hoy
existe otro tipo de universidad que se
llama internet que tiene más información
de lo que cualquier universidad en el
mundo nos podría ofrecer y además es
gratis
y así es como esta persona sea otro
formado con todos los recursos que
necesitaba y que los ha encontrado
disponibles en el internet y ha tomado
muchos y otro tipo de cursos sí entonces
mis amigos si con estas palabras de
michael sheiman todavía no les he podido
despertar un poquito la curiosidad
fíjense en esa imagen hoy como he
empezado mi presentación estamos
evolucionando como humanidad y cuando
estamos hablando de humanidad también
estamos hablando de que alguien nos está
pisando la cola que es la famosa
inteligencia artificial la creación del
ser humano seguramente en los próximos
años va a opacar al creador ya estamos
viendo aplicaciones muy interesantes de
inteligencia artificial de learning
machine learning de redes neuronales
etcétera sí que en muchos casos van a
reemplazar no a humanos pero si el
trabajo laborioso tedioso de los seres
humanos esas labores repetitivas y la
inteligencia artificial muy pronto nos
va a reemplazar
sí entonces eso es también un óbice para
que los que están estudiando malas
noticias la universidad cuando tú
terminas la universidad no estaba
educación sino que más bien comienza
estamos viviendo lo que los
norteamericanos llaman en lifelong
learning el aprendizaje a lo largo de
toda la vida y los mox nos van a ayudar
en este sentido entonces lo que quiero
resumir en dos pensamientos en mi
presentación es decir ustedes comiencen
a hackear su educación para que puedan
tener una mejor calidad de vida hoy y
los próximos años que les quedan por
delante les agradezco mucho muy amables